I'm always scared when I swim that
someone's going to go in there that's my
biggest I've had someone thing go in
there when I swim I've been sng with
jellyfish on my vagina what I was
swimming uh in Cuba when I was like
maybe 12 or 13 I went with my family and
we went the cousins went at night into
the water and I was wearing a tankini as
you do oh cool and pretty cool yeah and
um it was loose cuz it was my older
sister's tanky knee to be exact so it
was like a little baggy saggers in the
beginning anyways and then get in the
water and you know you think with waves
come and everybody jumps at the same
time keep your head above and I jumed
and it bed out on the bottom and a
jellyish went in and then it closed on
it and it was just in there like Banger
Chang ranging around in there like
stinging zipping zapping zoinking how
big was it I never saw it it was dark it
was under the water oh my God but I knew
that when I had it was after I jumped it
something build out and then I felt when
my bikini bottoms closed that there was
something like like would it feel like
like slimy in there not I think I I
didn't go in the front I grabbed because
it hurt so bad I grabbed the sides and
just pulled down the side so it then it
got I never touched it thank God cuz I
would have been stung probably even more